qué número se muestra con los bloques de
valor posicional aquí tenemos varios
conjuntos de bloques de valor posicional
algunos con muchos bloques y algunos
bloques simples apilados y queremos
saber qué números representan estos
bloques combinados así que vamos a
empezar aquí con estos bloques apilados
uno sobre otro porque será más fácil
contarlos y vamos a acercarlos un poco
para que sea más fácil contarlos y estos
bloques son simples unidades apilados
uno sobre otro
entonces los podemos contar y tenemos 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 bloques 9 bloques de
este lado continuamos y ahora tenemos
columnas de bloques y cada columna tiene
10 bloques porque aquí tenemos 9 bloques
más son bloques son 10 así que cada
columna tiene 10 bloques son decenas
cuantas escenas tenemos aquí 1 2 3 4 5 5
conjuntos de 10 bloques o 50 entonces
tenemos 50 bloques más 9 si avanzamos
tenemos estas columnas de 10 pero son
columnas de 10 pegadas y que hacen una
especie de pared cuántas columnas de 10
hay en esta pared una dos tres cuatro
cinco seis siete ocho nueve diez diez
renglones de diez o diez columnas de
diez que nos da un total de 100 así que
cada una de estas paredes tiene 100
bloques y cuántas paredes tenemos
tenemos una y dos hay una segunda parada
y atrás entonces tenemos dos centenas o
y finalmente vamos a movernos un poco y
tenemos estas paredes de 100 pegadas
unas con otras así que tenemos un
conjunto de 100 aquí y otro conjunto
aquí atrás y otros más atrás así que
vamos a contar cuántas centenas tenemos
100 200 300 400 500 600 700 800 900 y
1000 entonces tenemos millares estos son
millares y cuantos millares tenemos aquí
1 y 2
tenemos dos millares o 2.000 vamos a
regresar nos y a contar las cantidades
que tenemos tenemos dos mil bloques más
200 bloques más 50 bloques más 9 en
total tenemos dos mil doscientos
cincuenta y nueve bloques
vamos a hacer otro sabemos cuánto
representa cada uno de estos tamaños
esta columna del final representa las
unidades y aquí junto están las columnas
de las decenas sabemos que estas son
decenas y aquí no tenemos centenas no
tenemos las paredes que son diez
conjuntos de diez en este número no
tenemos ninguna centena
pero tenemos estos cubos grandes que
están formados por muchos bloques y que
son los millares porque son diez
conjuntos de 100 ahora vamos a contar
tenemos uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis
siete ocho unidades que es lo mismo que
ocho más tres decenas que es treinta no
tenemos centenas pero tenemos tres
millares que es tres mil así que al
combinar estos números debemos recordar
que no tenemos centenas nuestro número
es 3000
0 centenas y 38 3.038 es el número que
representan estos bloques de valor
posicional para este ejercicio los animo
a que pausa en el vídeo y vean si pueden
resolverlo por ustedes mismos qué
números representan estos bloques de
valor posicional
ahora podemos resolverlo juntos
recuerden
estas son unidades de escenas
centenas
y millares entonces si contamos las
unidades tenemos 12 34 unidades más 12
decenas que es 2010 + 10 es 20 más estas
centenas vamos a ver 100 200 300 400 500
600 700
más sólo un millar que es mil
ahora lo combinamos y tenemos que es mil
724 el número que representan estos
bloques de valor posicional